15 generations ist das nicht ein
bisschen viel
ich glaube ich habe 15 generate keine
batterien oder wie mit zornig wenn er
nicht mit erd- blocken angreift einfach
hoch fliegen und dann wird man als
angeber abgestellt
ein spaß mit veronique wollte ich auch
bald mal aufnehmen allerdings jetzt erst
mal will ich diese 15 minuten die sache
abhaken
dass ich jeden tag dann drei folgen
machte bis ich dann noch die 30 minuten
damit runtergeschraubt werden muss
beziehungsweise weil es die regel sagt
und ich bin ein mensch der sich an
regeln hält
ja bin gern bin ich da schon so gut
bogen habe ich da nicht unendlichkeit
achja ich brauche ein fein und dann habe
ich unendlich viel mehr oder weniger das
ist auf jeden fall schon mal ganz gut da
brauch ich auf jeden fall nur von
kleinen welt zuwenden so hier an alle
die das nicht mehr mit unendlich viel
bezahlt fall unfall und fall und fall
und ja ich kann allerdings kann davon
aufnehmen
sonst könne man sich unendlich viele
machen witzlos ein jetpack ist schon
fast wieder komplett aufgeladen
allerdings machen wir das solarpanel
noch ein bisschen zu wenig energie
deswegen schauen wir uns vielleicht das
back of phoenix an leader abgelöst hat
auf jeden fall brauche ich erst mal mehr
solarpanel das heißt ich brauche tast
und glas eine menge menge kohle tasten
menge glas kohl das gras fressen wenn
ihr bei subway holt euch auf jeden fall
die pappkarte das habe ich am wochenende
gemacht in wieder fällt leicht aber im
subway das ist so genial
ihr müsst euch einfach ins abkaufen und
die tutti sub card unter dieses gerät
das ist dann gerät das sieht ungefähr so
aus haltet die einfach so eure setcard
runter doch das blieb und dann ist das
abgas quasi so ein stent bescheid
abgespeichert und wenn irgendwann 10
sandwiches gekauft hat kriegt ihr
komplettes menü glaub ich kostenlos für
mich lohnt sich das extrem wasser besser
einzige fast food laden dem ich hingehe
weil darin dass wenigstens noch ein
bisschen gesund dass ich weiß aber
sollte mal geschlossen werden weil die
produkte wohl irgendwie doch nicht so
frisch wie weil es als eingelegt aber
auch hier verbessere als mecklenburger
team zusammen und das finde ich doch gar
nicht mehr weg ist ein burger king im
subway ist einfach geil und so also ich
brauche auf jeden fall gas und kohle
richtig viel klar so polen ist damit
jetzt auch langsam mehr anbieten der
leute wissen und glas und kohle
generator brauche ich eine menge und
elektronik circles bringe heißt ich muss
mich auf jeden fall noch eine menge gab
eine menge electronics show kids machen
wie mache ich die nummer cable redstone
rief ein teil
redstone rief ein tierisch so nochmal
kurz rezept angucken kopper cable rief
ihren koffer kate einen redstone halte
ich habe einfach mal viel zu wenig
kompatibel
wie mache ich mir kopper cable leute
cable kupfer und kupfer
dann kann ich noch nicht so viel kabel
davon machen das jetzt macht sinn ergibt
soll uns nicht locken
18 reicht erstmal von anfang so deswegen
brauche ich auf jeden fall krems
toptarif ein tier im redstone von kupfer
kann man echt nicht zu viel kriegen ihr
das ist echt das allerwichtigste
jetzt habe ich schon mal neuen
elektronik circus
so electronics werkes habe ich generell
tarif einteilen und island furnish eine
menge eisen richtig viele randvoll das
ist ich mein ich brauche ja später auch
sehr viele freunde kann sein dass meine
fans kaum jemand mit aufgeht ausgeht und
ich dass am ende alles irgendwie
begreifen oder soll ich mich schon
entschuldigen so ein schönes und
batterie habe ich weiß dass ich ein
bisschen viel
ich habe 15 generate auch keine batterie
mehr nein nein da kommt erst mal eine
kuh angeschlossen hier mag ich habe 15
generate aber nur ein element von anja
einen vers bäuerlich generate elektronik
circuit als habe ich eigentlich alles
generator electronics circuit die zimmer
weiter herr kohl viel mehr geht nicht
weil ich mehr elektronik circus brauche
fakt ich könnte mir noch ab sechs könnte
ich mir noch machen ich habe jetzt vier
auf jeden fall
ich brauche für sonnen low voltage den
brauche ich drei vier fünf sechs 788
unterbett box durch imitate lv
transformer der ist einfach brauche ich
achte ich habe 5 das heißt ich brauche
noch drei
das heißt wie viele elektronik circus
brauche ich dafür noch als ich brauche
sechs heißt ich brauche noch 5 das heißt
ich brauche auf jeden fall das einzige
was braucht es echt kupfer leute
höhlentour das wird erstmal hier der
kiste gelagert was ich nicht auch alles
brot bogen ihr kommt auch alle mit ich
brauche ich nicht verkennen brauche ich
den iranischen und norma mit einem pfeil
für den links und was man auch nie
vergessen sollte in höhlen holz ganz
simpel ist das noch aufladen von meinen
sachen die ich habe
egal welche mit dem nächsten wochen
sowieso und jetzt eine höhle leute und
zwar versetzt denn da bitte lover hin
schaut mal habe ich eher abgebaut
das ist meine erste loch so ich würde
sagen wir schauen einfach in der wüste
das heißt ich sprinte erst mal hin weil
mit diesen mit dem jetpack und so zu
fliegen das ist weiß nicht dass das
selbst mal so langsam oder ist man
dadurch ist man damit schneller
doch man ist deutschland schon so
schnell dass nicht doch von oben dann
halt zu wenig aus zu langsam so kühl
muss immer zurück und werde google cloud
ich glaube immer noch dass das dass
jemand geklaut hat und nicht mobile also
hier ein bisschen holz alternativlos so
cool ist auch nicht einfach keinen fall
scheint das heißt nicht fallen runter
kein ding so geht nun mal hier setzt das
ding raus hallo setzlinge hallo
so fliegen war weiter so da oben sind
kakaobohnen dingsbums kann immer noch
nachher holen wo massaker seien
baumwollstoff zeit mal abbauen
ich fühle mich echt wie im creative mord
gerade mit dem jetpack gibt es hier von
setzlingen wenn es darf und setzlinge
gibt ich bau aus die ich möchte am
liebsten diese ganzen blätter die hier
dran sind für mein haus einfach
verwenden ich glaube ich fliege jetzt
auch schnell nach hause und hole mir
noch eine schere kommt dass nur freunde
kupfer alles mitnehmen was gibt ja so
ist schaut mal ganz kurz in den
einstellungen komme ich packte jetzt mal
ganz kurz die sonst silva wirklich packt
das immer ganz gut wieder dran
damit die blätter noch ein bisschen
länger dran bleiben so und jetzt suchen
wir uns einfach eine höhle oder wir
kennen noch mal ganz kurze runde dann
kann ich auch in der schere holen
oder wieso und seine höhle was da achter
brands ja cool mensch wir fliegen direkt
wieder nach hause das war eine tolle
höhlentour nähe einfach weil ich noch ne
peña muss scheiße der entlädt sich jetzt
die ganze zeit weil halt nacht ist das
dann auch besser wegen dem jetpack also
man nähert sich dann statt auf jeden
fall relativ schnell ich bin auch
eigentlich relativ schnell wenn man sich
das angucken ja das sieht jetzt so
relativ wenig aus aber wenn ich jetzt
zum beispiel so her fliegen ist schon
schnell
ich möchte mich da natürlich nicht
beschwert ich finde auch mein grundstück
ehrlich gesagt über 7 und 7 aus ich
finde mein grundstück mit am schönsten
also ich möchte mich jetzt nicht selber
loben aber finde ich schon schön so
einfach so ein bisschen abgehoben fall
sei
hier könnte bis auf voll abgeboten
einfach so abgehoben so von den anderen
grundstücken einfach so ein bisschen
sogar darüber dass das so eingezäunt ist
und so egal erstmal ohne pannen so
können ordentlich zu die berliner
eigentlich kann ich auch mein ratschlag
so jetzt mein helm lässt sich wieder auf
was ist das da hinten weiß ich nicht der
schädling zum kreuz
die schere habe ich vergessen haben die
kommentare im helferteam bestimmt auch
in den ofen server geht sagte dann hey
du kannst mir die ecke geklaut babler
weil ich jede braut war nie aber wir
nehmen ja immer alle auf von daher kann
ich letztendlich glaube ich acht
kofferraum machen oder 113
dann kann ich auf jeden fall schon ein
paar cable machen ich bin übrigens
krater bayern alle die jetzt vielleicht
hat erst dazuschalten finger hat dabei
mir ein low voltage solarenergie blaha
schweben mir ein low voltage blabla zu
holen
low voltage solar ding das da low
voltage solar york bei klick dich nicht
weil das mir mehr energie gibt auf jeden
fall schon mal genug wie ich jetzt
erstmal brauche zeit und dafür brauche
ich acht solarpanel und 1 nv transformer
der relativ einfach zu kräften ist
allerdings die solarpanels verlangen
stand eine menge elektronik circus
körper cable et cetera deswegen brauche
ich auf jeden fall schon eine menge
kupfer ja kann ich mir holen
viele dort zwar ein bisschen lange mit
aber das ist es mir wert diese geile
blauen blätter sind immer gesagt 100
blöcke von der fertig bin 234 entfernt
also hat hier alles seine richtigkeit
ich kann ich noch ein bisschen wolle
heben mitnimmt macht er so lange bis die
schere kaputtes weil ich denke nicht
dass noch das ist noch kleinere bäume
gibt in diesem spiel weil ich finde
dieses blaue blitze wenn ich das nochmal
gut hinkriege dass es dann bei mir auch
blitzer dann wäre das so geil vor allem
leuchtet das sogar im dunkeln oder
möchte dass ich weiß ich gar nicht
also wenn ihr euch fragt wieso hakes
blabla trainer nebenbei noch als folge
27 28 so was alles muss jetzt ein
bisschen gas geben dem hochladen damit
ich das auch ausnutzen kann dieses 45
minuten links darunter reicht das erst
mal 36
das reicht nicht man kann nie genug
davon trinkt
gleiches alles weg dann ab in die höhe
da wo finden wir eine höhle leute hier
waren schon welche ja hier waren schon
welche roman was du das ist ein haus
das ist ein haus glaube ich ja hier war
schon welche so schade
na gut wo könnte mir eine höhle finden
das auf jeden fall eine wüste das nicht
so viele höhen
das ist ein baumstumpf das ist er macht
sich denn bitte sowas hier oder ist es
von ruins dingsbums plan zugefügt worden
aber sonst verbraucht sich denn so was
wir nicht können dass er theoretisch
abbauen
ja gut dass wieder so typisch minecraft
wüst und schnecken schnebeck direkt
aneinander an
na gut so weiter geht es folgende ein
jetpack aufgeladenes entlädt sich immer
mehr aber da ja ja ja das blöde ist halt
die ganzen sachen die wurden alle schon
entdeckt da waren überall schon leute
drin da ist eine ölquelle glaube ich ja
das ist schon etwas mal ganz kurz zu
boden
ja solche nicht da wo ich mal hinsetzen
die dann einfach massaker aus dass es
darum das ist auch so green spot mäßig
plan
so schaut auch mal ganz kurz rein
doch noch keiner aber das sind beklagt
hatten
ich könnte mir eine hohe brauche ich
auch noch die ganze sportfirma nach und
nach ab das ist relativ simpel
okay okay ich verabschiede mich das ist
halt so dass geil einem jetpack ja ich
kann einfach mal so wegfliegen jetzt
wenn ich will
ich möchte einfach nur eine höhle eine
ganz alte schöne hülle dahinter ist
obsidian ich warte man nun auf die
allerdings machen dass kohle kohle kann
man auch nie genug von kriegen weil man
damit natürlich immer mal so wenn man
keine hier einfach sich ein generator
antreiben kann
ich setze das jetpack an die das liegt
sicher gerade auf oder negativ so legt
es auf
so legt sich auf aber so egal ich nehme
auf jeden fall erstmal alles mit auch
wenn es mich stört die ganze kohle mit
zunehmendem wurz tausendmal geschrieben
die kohle mit mache ich jetzt auch schon
mit dem jetpack ab
wenn ich in der höhle haben wie ich
schon gesagt hat sich mehrfach den
eisenbacher aufnahmen pass möchte sich
so viel kohle mit einem solch wichtig
denn nur wenn kupfer losgegangen
da hinten wieder lava ich glaube ich war
immer mit böser wolf getötet danke fahne
lover einmal kann ja nie schaden
so haben wir hier höhlen haben wir
empfohlen da haben wir es mal kupfer
peking
ja na gut also bevor ich die türe ich
könnte mir eigentlich und links von den
bullen wolle einfach coopers auf einmal
daraufhin weg jetzt mir eure wollen ist
ausgegangen
schon länger aber ich habe jetzt erst
gemerkt weil das so gemacht hat
so und du da oben weg möchte auch gleich
am liebsten erst mal cut machen bevor
mir dass die gleiche zeit
bevor mir dass sie gleich nochmal
abstützt war ja schon mal und dann auch
mal eine kreditaufnahme einfach weg so
war denn jetzt noch koffer da und nur
noch körperlich die ganze zeit
durchgängig ich glaube ich mache jetzt
jetzt genau ist eigentlich perfekte zeit
jetzt erstmal katzen machen
deswegen sage ich euch freunde ich stopp
das ganze jetzt mal ganz kurz meine
facetime ist ausgegangen von daher würde
ich sagen die chefs schon da und dann
sichten wir